Guten Morgen Linos.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Bei dieser ganzen Cyber-Indoktrination muss man sich ja langsam Gedanken machen, ob nicht irgendwann auch die schönsten und besten auf Linie gebracht werden.
Das hier ist mein Laptop. Es gibt viele andere, aber dies ist meins. Mein Laptop ist mein bester Freund,
Es ist mein Leben. Ich muss es meistern, wie ich mein Leben meistern muss,
ohne mich ist mein Laptop nutzlos, ohne meinen Laptop bin auch ich nutzlos,
Mein Laptop verfehlt sein Ziel nie. Ich muss schneller tippen als mein Feind. Denn sonst hackt er mich. Ich muss ihn hacken, bevor er mich hackt. Das werde ich,
vor Gott glaube ich und schwöre. Mein Laptop und ich werden mein Vaterland verteidigen,
Wir sind die Bezwinger unserer Feinde, wir sind die Bewahrer meines Lebens. Das schwöre ich bis kein Feind mehr ist nur Frieden. Amen.
Herzlich willkommen zur Friedenssichersten Sendung, die es im Podcast-Universum jemals gegeben hat. Ja ja muss man aufpassen.
Ja. Man muss vorsichtig sein.
Sonst geht es auch mal gleich in die andere Richtung. Rüstet. Aber wir passen ja auf, oder? Wir haben das im Blick. Wir ähm lassen nichts äh durchrutschen und ähm.
Doch uns ist was durchgerutscht. Letzte letzte Sendung.
Oh Gott.
Ja. Peinlich, sogar peinlich. Peinlich. Ja.
Peinliches, na endlich mal was peinliches.
Macht man, so macht man sie auf sich aufmerksam, ja?
Ja so peinlich ist es auch nicht.
Weil Majestätsbeleidigung.
Konstanze sprach den Film die Anwälte an.
Und äh meinte, dass Gerd Baum darin eine Rolle gespielt habe, das hat er nicht und ich dachte mir das auch schon so, als sie das sagte, aber dann
gab ich in den Google einen Gerhard Baum die Anwälte und es gab sehr viele Treffer unter anderem einen Artikel auf Zeit online, dachte ich auch krass, der war da offenbar auch in dem Film. Ähm, der Artikellaufzeit online war ein Artikel von Gerhard Baum
dass dieser Film scheiße ist.
Also Ströble, Maler, Chili. Genau. Ja.
Genau und nicht ähm Baum. Also äh Gerhard Baum mit Otto Schile zu verwechseln äh würden glaube ich beide äh nicht witzig.
Meint man sich mal. Maler wahrscheinlich auch.
Horst Maler äh mit Horst Maler will man auch nicht verwechselt werden. Mit Ströbele.
Nee. Da könnt ihr glaube ich, da könnt ihr glaube ich mit Slag kommen. Ja, denke auch.
Daraus wäre in Ordnung, das würde wahrscheinlich anmahnen, aber auf sich sitzen lassen.
Ja, ist schon interessant, dass vor diesen drei Terroradwälten der siebziger quasi nur einer wirklich saden äh übrig geblieben ist.
Ich sage jetzt nicht, welche an.
Ist ja auch für jeden für jede Richtung was dabei, ne? Also von daher einmal links, einmal rechts, einmal äh stramme Mitte.
Also sich mit dieser mit dieser gesamten äh mit diesen Raffanwälten und dieser ganzen Geschichte da auseinandersetzen, überhaupt mit dieser äh Raffgeschichte, das ist halt ich für ähm äußerst empfehlenswert. Grundsätzlich als allgemeine Bundesbildung. Das ist ähm
höchst interessant.
Der überhaupt hat, haben die Siebziger dann doch äh einen deutlicheren Fußabdruck hinterlassen als äh so einige andere Jahrzehnte. Also ich würde sogar fast sagen in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik,
War das eigentlich der schwerwiegendste Ruck, der durch dieses Land mal gegangen ist, so
Achtziger waren eher fremdbestimmt, die Neunziger waren irgendwie im Drogenrausch äh verkramt und äh.
Aber nicht bei den bei der Politik.
Was? Ach so, echt?
Mich da gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Der Kohl die ganze Zeit auf Essen.
Gab's nochmal Feedback.
Ja, es gab ähm zur vorletzten Sendung ähm Kritik,
dass ich oder es war, waren da einige hörende Nichter der Meinung dass ich dass es ein keine legitimen Gründe gäbe Briefkastenfirmen zu haben wie ich es gesagt hatte.
Ähm und wiesen dann auf die Mannikfachen,
Möglichkeiten hin, via Whisleblower und wer nicht alles sich mittels Briefkastenfirmen
vor der Unterdrückung bewahren oder so und es wurde auch darauf hingewiesen, wie ich denn Bitcoin befürworten könne, aber Briefkastenfirmen nicht
Ähm dazu fällt mir,
primär ein, äh, dass Bitcoin eine Währung ist und 'ne Briefkastenfirma eine Firma, also da sehe ich nennenswerten Unterschied im Konzept, ähm,
und,
gleichzeitig ist es aber natürlich, klar, könnte sein, dass ich irgendwann auch gezwungen bin, äh ähm eine eine Briefkastenfirma zu machen, weil die Bundesrepublik Deutschland mich verfolgt. Äh das ist denkbar,
ähm
Wir werden dann sehen äh in zwei Wochen oder was werden ja diese Panama-Papers dann mal veröffentlicht? Also alle Firmen, die Firmendatenbank wird veröffentlicht. Äh dann werden wir sehen, wie viele Wistel Blower da äh den Schutz
vor der Verfolgung gesucht haben und dann werden wir irgendwann vielleicht auch nochmal diskutieren, ob das,
Ne, ob das Unterdrückte sind. Ich meine, vielleicht sind das alles Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge, ne? Kann ja sein. Vielleicht haben die wurden die alle verfolgt.
Und äh der Gemeindestaat wollte sie enteignen. Ähm ich halte das äh für.
Schwieriger Herleit war das jetzt so in den Briefkastenfirma, die Millionen umsetzt, ähm.
In legitim ist und ich denke auch, dass was diese Briefkastenfirmen ja ausmacht ist nicht dass sie oder was ich damit meinte ist
nicht, dass sie irgendwo in einem anderen Land ihren Sitz haben. Jeder Mensch soll natürlich von mir aus in der Lage sein
im Land seiner Wahl ein Geschäft zu eröffnen, das ist dann das wird zwar auch Schwierigkeiten drauf, aber das ist am Ende wahrscheinlich in Ordnung. Was vermutlich nicht in Ordnung ist, ist, dass da ähm.
Auf fremde Rechnungen äh beforgen betrieben wird. Also mit diesen Sockenpuppen.
Genau, also es geht halt um die es geht um die Verschleierung der äh begünstigsten,
dann äh ich habe auch noch, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jetzt bei uns geführt wurde, diese Debatte oder noch woanders, aber äh es gab noch so den Hinweis, dass ja unter anderem auch solche äh Unternehmen solche Schutzunternehmen benutzt würden, um zum Beispiel Marken
sich zu sichern für neue Produkte bevor sie das Licht der Öffentlichkeit sehen,
Ja, mag sein, dass das eine Anwendung ist, allerdings muss man halt auch sehen, wenn wenn das das einzige legitime Ziel ist,
Dann ist es sicherlich jetzt kein großes Problem für solche Fälle in irgendeiner Form ein Modell zu finden, ein ein rechtliches Modell zu finden. Ähm was weiß ich, dass man das zum Beispiel mit dem Staat,
registriert,
ein Unternehmen, das da sozusagen klar ist, wer dahinter steckt und so und das auch was weiß ich, eine Ablauffrist hat et cetera. Also alle möglichen Modelle kann man sich dabei vorstellen und es nun wirklich nicht erforderlich, dass so in so.
Kleine Länder aus.
Neu erstens das und zweitens wenn du irgendwelche ich mein du wirst ja als großes Unternehmen das irgendwie ein Produkt launchen will mehr können.
Also wird's ja wohl mehr Vertraute auf der Welt haben als irgendwelche panamaischen äh Sockenpuppenanwälte.
Website nicht pur mitbekommen.
Also,
aber wie gesagt, okay, es gibt es gibt immer vermutlich auch denkbare, legitime Anwendungszwecke für jedes Mittel. Ähm ich halte das für sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass wir einen nennenswerten Anteil derartiger finden werden,
in diesen Panama Papers.
Na ja, aber vielleicht erzählst du jetzt mal von deinen neuen militärischen Ausrichtungen.
Ja, ich hoffe, äh also es äh.
Es wurde veröffentlicht vom äh Bundesministerium für Verteidigung äh der äh sogenannte Abschlussbericht des Aufbaustab Cyber und Informationsraum,
Das ist ja ein Thema, was uns jetzt schon seit einiger Zeit begleitet, dass die ähm Bundeswehr.
Ähm in den Cyber äh gehen möchte. Ähm
sagt in der Sendung mit Andre haben wir darüber gesprochen beim Camp. Ähm dass man sich jetzt eben überlegt, man hat irgendwie Luftboden und Wasser und Cyber als Cyber kommt quasi dazu.
Das kriegen wir nicht mehr weg, oder?
Das ist oh.
Das Wort kriegen wir nicht mehr weg.
Also die Nenner, die nennen das.
Wie nennen sie's selber die internationalen Datensätze werden als mit militärischer Operationsraum definiert? Ja. Also das ist tatsächlich so, sie wollen eben Cyberoperationen, das sind auch die Begriffe, die sie nutzen.
Ja, ich weiß, ich bin nur nach wie vor schockiert.
Ja ähm da haben sie jetzt eben gesagt, okay, wir werden diese ähm
die Abteilung Cyber und Informationsraum im Verteidigungsministerium schaffen mit einhundertdreißig äh Mitarbeitern und die Streitkräfte wollen sie äh in Richtung äh Cyber ähm um,
umbauen, das ist dann der das Kommando CER, das ist glaube ich Cyber, das steht für Cyber und Informationsraum.
Wenn es in solchen Abkürzungen drin ist, dann kriegt man's nicht mehr weg.
Ich wundere mich gerade, dass äh bei Spiegel online steht, der würde CIR heißen, ich lese in dem Bericht aber eher nur CET.
Nein, das.
Cyber-IT.
Also es gibt den den Organisationsbereich Kommando CER. Äh der also Cyber und Informationsraum,
Ähm und da werden dreizehntausendsiebenhundert äh Dienstposten zusammengeführt,
Also wir brauchen wir werden um die vierzehnhundert äh äh tausend, vierzehntausend Cyber-Soldaten haben. Äh der größere Teil soll aber von dem aus dem aktuellen Bereich kommen und also quasi sie wollen,
innerhalb der der Bundeswehr irgendwie umschulen und umstrukturieren, also nicht vergrößern.
Und der Rest wird halt irgendwo dann gesucht. Jetzt muss ich noch kurz überlegen. Also im Bundesverteidigungsministerium ist es,
Cyber-IT, CIT ist die Abteilung und bei der Bundeswehr ist es dann das Kommando Cyber und Informationsraum CIR.
Ja, für die Stelle im äh Verteidigungsministerium wollen sie sich einen Manager von Thyssenkrupp äh holen,
der also wird jetzt gemunkelt, Klaus Hardi Mühleck, der soll dort der Chief Information Officer werden und bei dem bei dem militärischen Teil wollen Sie bis nächstes Jahr, bis zum nächsten Jahr,
Ähm eben dieses äh Kommando CER aufbauen und da wird vermutlich der Generalmajor Ludwig
Leinhos, ein drei Sterne General, hast du alles nicht gesehen, äh irgendwelche hochdekorierten Krieger äh werden dann da die die Kommandos leiden.
Ludwig Kleinhos.
Interessant ist dann zu sehen.
Luftwaffe.
Ja, genau, also und man wird eben sehen, ob die Bundeswehr das.
Sozusagen von der Luft in den in den Cyber. Ja. Natürlicher Übergang glaube ich.
Wer zu hoch fliegt. Ähm na ja, die viel mehr kann man da jetzt nicht zu sagen. Es wird interessant zu sehen, wie die,
schaffen wollen, also sie werden ja nicht in der Lage sein mit den mit der freien Wirtschaft zu konkurrieren, mit ihren Soldatengeldern da. Ähm, das ist ein Problem, dessen sie sich auch bewusst sind und was sie durch äh eben hervorragende Ausbildung
ähm,
lösen wollen. Das ist tatsächlich so, wenn man jetzt in Staaten schaut, die schon, sage ich mal, länger in diesem Cyberbereich äh zugange sind oder auch wenn man in Richtung der Geheimdienste schaut, ähm Menschen, die,
zehn Jahre in so einem Bereich irgendwie gedient haben. Ähm die haben natürlich dann äh ganz gute äh Möglichkeiten,
in der in der Wirtschaft irgendwie loszugehen.
Ja genau und vor allem dreht.
Bionage erfährst du dann halt ein Cyberroop-Krieger oder sowas bei dir im Unternehmen.
Genau und es dreht sich dann sozusagen um, ne? Also äh junge Leute sehen ja dann oft auch in der Bundeswehr sozusagen für sich ein ähm.
Perspektive, so kostenlose Ausbildung da, und man interessiert sich für Computer, dann mache ich doch mal ein bisschen Cyber und so. Naja und dann steht sie halt irgendwann vor einem Securityunternehmen und kriegen die Frage so, haben sie gedient? Jawohl, ist Cyber.
Und dann ist man dabei, ja? Also früher hast du da äh Trecker fahren gelernt und jetzt äh lernst du halt tippen.
Da bin ich ja echt froh, dass ich irgendwie in diese so geharrschaft in diese Generation geraten bin, wo man nicht mehr gefragt wird, ob man gedient hat. Und wenn, dass man einfach natürlich nicht ist verrückt oder was? Meine Güte, ey.
Verrückt oder was? Ja, ja. Kann dauer kommen. Na gut, aber wir wissen ja nicht die äh einzigen, die hier rumsabern.
Ja die äh die USA Salban jetzt auch massiv. Ähm die haben das sind auch irgendwie solche komischen das sind so Meldungen wo du dich auch fragst was ist jetzt so ähm.
Die USA haben jetzt angekündigt, sie werden äh jetzt gegen den gegen die Gruppe, die da sich islamischer Staat nennt, ähm mit Cyberwaffen vorgehen.
Das Ziel dieser Kampagne soll sein ähm deren Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten einzuschränken und sie dadurch dann zu hindern ihre Botschaft zu ähm,
Ihre Botschaft in die Welt zu setzen, neue Leute zu bekommen und auch ähm ihre äh Befehle,
an die einzelnen Gruppen zu bringen, ja? Also dass sie quasi in ihrer täglichen Kriegsführung gestört werden sollen durch das durch Angriffe auf ihre Kommunikationsinfrastrukturen. Ähm.
Die nicht ganz unerheblich sind.
Ja ja und dann kommt.
Geyer, wie viele Einsätze da schon über WhatsApp gefahren werden.
Dann hatte ich dann hatte er äh der Verteidigungsminister Escht einen Kater relativ wenig dazu gesagt, aber der Fans, also der stellvertretende.
Verteidigungssekretär oder wie auch immer man das nennen würde. Äh hat dann geschrieben.
We are dropping Cyberbombs. We have a never tham that before,
Cyberbons. Also die ich weiß nicht, was er sich damit vorstellt, aber ja, die USA werfen also jetzt Cyberbomben auf äh auf den islamischen Staat. Keiner weiß, was das bedeutet. Man kann sich das ungefähr vorstellen, was es ähm,
was sie damit meinen.
Nachkonzertierte IT-Angriffe.
Ja, ja, im Zweifelsfall, ja, aber was mit welchem Ziel, ja.
Ich will das nur markieren, weil das eben jetzt quasi den Zeitpunkt benennt. In dem offiziell zum ersten Mal ein.
Ein wirklicher Cyberkrieg von einer militärischen Stelle benannt und ausgerufen ist,
Das war mir vorher schien das eher in dem in dem Geheimdienstebereich zu sein und hier mir klingt es jetzt so, als könnte man sagen, dass jetzt zum ersten Mal ein Cyber-Krieg erklärt wurde
Wir haben das schon vorher gemacht, aber jetzt ist zum ersten Mal, dass man sagt, wir werfen jetzt Cyberbomben, ne.
Also wir werden jetzt noch über die nächsten Jahre sehen, wie eben dieses schöne äh Netz des Friedens, äh was wir hier mal ein paar Jahre lang hatten. Äh jetzt im massiv,
als als Einsatzbereich des des Militärs gesehen wird, als wenn es nicht schon gereicht hätte, äh dass die Geheimdienste da drin sind.
Ist natürlich auch insofern interessant, als das ja äh der Kampfraum Syrien äh ohnehin schon seit vielen Jahren
auch zu so einer Art Showroom äh geworden ist, da wird halt das mal wieder so alles äh zum Besten gegeben, was man so hat, äh auch die Russen äh
konnten mal wieder schön die Vorzüge ihrer aktuellen Militärtechnik dort äh demonstrieren und warum sollte das jetzt nicht auch die Cyberwaffen,
sozusagen. Weil anschließend wobei, ich glaube, der Vergleich äh hängt natürlich ein wenig, um das gleiche anzuschränken. Hier ist es sicherlich ähm Technologie, die die USA nicht auf dem freien Markt äh anbieten will,
Ja. Aber zumindest haut ihnen keiner auf die Finger dafür. Weil ist ja gegen die Bösen.
Apropos die Bösen. Ähm in einem in einem also.
Zum ersten Mal habe ich diese äh habe ich das vor, das ist schon vor einigen Monaten gewesen. Da hat so ein ähm.
Da gab's einen sehr denkwürdigen Artikel in der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung oder ich glaube in der wahrscheinlich auch in der Gedukten von ähm Sandro Geigen, äh der in einem seiner wirklich eher,
ähm komischen Momente, dann irgendwie diese gesamte Snowden-Affäre, als eine große Verschwörung der Russen. Ähm
schilderte, schilderte und dann irgendwie sagte, also so eine so ein Kuibono, ja? Ha, schaut doch mal, äh, wer profitiert denn hier und.
Ich fand das eher ähm.
Eher schwierig nachvollziehbar, äh, die Argumentation. Ähm, offenbar äh gibt es aber jetzt weitere Versuche, diese gesamte Angelegenheit in der Form zu deuten. Äh und die wurden jetzt äh unternommen von.
Georg Maaßen und dem Herr Gerhard Schindler, Maaßen äh ja äh Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz
Schindler noch BND, die haben den Fokus ein Interview gegeben, in dem dann Maaßen sagt, die Veröffentlichung des Nordenpapiere hat insbesondere Deutschland, den USA und anderen westlichen Staaten geschadet,
Es ist auffällig, dass es keine Veröffentlichung zu Ländern wie China oder Russland gibt, die doch Hauptaufklärungsziele der NSA-Observation sind,
Der Verrat der Geheimdienstunterlagen ist ein Versuch einen Keil zwischen Westeuropa und die USA zu treiben.
Den größten seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Nun.
Es lässt sich sehr einfach erklären, warum, wie er benennt, es keine Veröffentlichungen zu Ländern wie China oder Russland gibt,
Edward Snowden ist ein Wissle Blower darüber wie Geheimdienste vorgehen und wie sie die Rechte jener verletzen
für die sie eigentlich kämpfen, wie sie die Rechte jener Bevölkerung verletzen, zu deren Schutz, äh sie ins Leben gerufen wurden. Und er sagt, er,
deckt auf, wie US-Geheimdienste amerikanische Telefonnetze überwachen, er deckt auf, wie sie soziale Netzwerke überwachen,
In denen sich selbstverständlich auch ähm äh Chinesen oder Russen äh befinden. Er denk
er hat auch aufgedeckt mit welchen Methoden äh sie vorgehen, wie sie zum Beispiel Hardware verwanzen und so weiter. Ähm inhaltlich hat er aber natürlich wenig über eine geheimdienstliche Kooperation der NSA mit China und Russland,
weil diese im Zweifelsfall einfach grundsätzlich nicht existiert, denn die sind ja Feinde und AdWords Noten ist ein Whisle Blower über das über die
Verletzungen von Grundrechten durch die
überregionale Kooperation von Geheimdiensten. Und aus diesem Grunde findet sich da nichts äh nennenswertes über China oder Russland
Das ist also nicht so, als würde Edward Snoden irgendwo sitzen und sagen, nee, nee, äh die Sachen mit China und Russland, die veröffentlichen wir nicht, das ist einfach überhaupt gar nicht sein Ziel. Ja, äh also das ist äh.
Ist ja auch nicht Wiki Leaks, dem jetzt alles gesteckt wird, sondern er hat halt einmal von der NSA alles rausgetragen und da das, dass es sich bei NSA-Dokumenten im Wesentlichen um die NSA handelt, ist jetzt irgendwie nicht sonderlich überraschend, oder?
Richtig. Dann äh beschwert er sich, er würde inzwischen mehr Referenten in seinem Hause mit dem NSA seinen, in seinem Hause mehr Referent mit dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss beschäftigt, als mit dem Bereich islamischer Terrorismus,
das ist finde ich auch eine sehr.
Bösartige Darstellung, denn der Bereich islamischer Terrorismus scheint zumindest im Moment noch in Deutschland auch wirklich das sehr viel kleinere Problem zu sein.
Wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie viele wie viel Recht in welchem Bereich gebrochen wird und wie viele Menschen wo zu Schaden kommen.
Und äh es ist natürlich auch hier eine relativ ähm plumper äh Versuch. Ähm,
gegen so etwas vorzugehen. Mich würde mal interessieren, äh
Wie viele Referenten in seinem Hause denn mit dem Bereich rechter Terrorismus in Deutschland beschäftigt sind. Das scheint eigentlich gerade ein größeres Problem
zu sein, wenn man Inlandsgeheimnis der Deutsche wäre, aber ich will ihn da nicht reinreden, wie man seine Arbeit macht, ich muss das nur mal kurz anmerken, weil er sich ja gerade einmischt
wie Edwards Norden seine Arbeit macht.
Ähm Schindler fügte dann noch hinzu. Die Russen sind sehr gut darin, sogenannte psychologische Operationen durchzuführen. Die Ziele lauten Ukraine, die baltischen Staaten, Westeuropa insgesamt, also auch Deutschland
Dabei nutzen die Russen das gesamte mediale Spektrum, vor allem auch die sozialen Netzwerke.
Also wenn es dann losgeht, wenn wenn das losgeht, dass sie darüber reden, der Russe macht Psychops, ne.
Das wäre dann auch der Moment, an dem ich äh sagen würde, vielleicht wäre es gar nicht so verkehrt, wenn der gute Mann jetzt mal Frührentner wird.
Weil bei dem offensichtlich Einblicke in die in die äh Kulturgeschichte von Geheimdiensten fehlt irgendwie. Haben die jemals was anderes gemacht? Also das ist.
Maßen fügt den, also du fragst dich ernsthaft,
dann sagt Maaßen noch, es gäbe Hinweise, es gäbe Hinweise, dass der Kremel jede Gelegenheit nutzt, um Deutschland zu diskreditieren,
Desinformation, Infiltration, Einflussnahme, Propaganda und Zersetzung. Es gibt Hinweise darauf.
Will der uns alle irgendwie zum will er uns verarschen?
So und jetzt schau dir mal an,
ich habe ich habe zum Beispiel auch, ich habe Hinweise darauf, ich kann die Quellen jetzt nicht offenlegen. Ich habe aber Hinweise darauf, dass Deutschland jede Gelegenheit nutzt, um Russland zu diskreditieren. Und weißt du, wo ich diese Hinweise finde, wenn ich eine Zeitung aufmache,
So und wenn ich mir angucke, was die jeden Tag reden, ne? Also diese, es ist eine.
In einem Punkt haben sie Recht. Der der Keil, der hier getrieben wird zwischen Deutschland und Russland. Ähm der ist größer als äh,
lange,
oder nein, der also er spricht ja von einem Kai zwischen Deutschland und den USA. Aber es wird ein Kai getrieben zwischen Deutschland und Russland und der ist äh größer den
denn in den letzten äh fünfundzwanzig dreißig Jahren, man hatte sich ja eigentlich halbwegs mal wieder eingekriegt so und ähm,
gegen so also eine nicht mehr rationale Feindlichkeit gegenüber allem, was ähm.
Was Russland macht oder Putin macht, äh kann man glaube ich in Deutschland im Moment diagnostizieren. Ich halte äh dass die Regierung in Russland nicht für eine besonders ähm.
Äh nicht für eine besonders äh gute und oder eine Sonne vertrauenswürdige.
Mhm.
Aber es ist schon schwierig sich im Moment.
Mal eine Einschätzung russischer Politik zu suchen, die nicht einfach nur die ganze Zeit auf Putins niedere Motive äh eindrischt. Ähm.
Wir hätten ja genug andere Partner, bei denen man das genauso machen könnte, ja? Also mit so einem mit so einem Erdogan äh dem lässt man ja eine ganze Menge durchgehen, ne? Wow, das ist ja völlig in Ordnung, aber dem also in über in Deutschland wird, dass es in über,
Konflikte mit Russland gerade nicht besonders äh objektiv und äh erklärend äh berichtet,
und in Russland natürlich genauso wenig,
dass die Russen die russische Regierung versucht ähm Deutschland zu diskreditieren. Ich bin froh, dass wir das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz haben, weil sonst wüssten wir das nicht.
Also sonst wüssten wir nicht, dass es Hinweise darauf gibt.
Finden alles raus.
Ja, findet alles raus. Aber man hat äh so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als wäre ähm Herr Schindler einfach nicht mehr so ganz seinem Job gewachsen, kann das sein.
Ja, das ist ähm denke ich ziemlich klar der Fall. Äh man.
Sieht ihn ja in im Rahmen des NSR-Untersuchungsausschusses ähm und jetzt hat der äh,
Erstmal ein einstweiligen Ruhestand vor sich, der so wird es gerüchtet vom Kanzleramt forciert wurde. Also man hat ihn äh quasi äh früh verrentet äh gegen seinen,
Vermutlich gegen seinen Willen.
Norde ist abgesägt.
Ja als als Begründung wird also es gibt keine offizielle Begründung ähm aber es hat vermutlich mehrere Gründe, erstens ähm.
Man hatte diese gesamte Bad Aibling Geschichte, wo der BND ungeprüft äh die Selektoren der NSA genutzt hat. Äh äh die,
übernommen hat und eben quasi für die NSA gegen äh europäische Verbündete und auch deutsche äh spioniert hat. Äh das ist natürlich schon so ein Grund für einen Rücktritt ähm,
dann hat sich im NSL Untersuchungsausschuss Ausschuss äh durchaus gezeigt, dass er,
nicht jedes seiner Referate da im Griff hat, die teilweise ein Eigenleben führen und er eben in Kontrolle und Aufsicht da nicht der Beste zu sein scheint.
Ähm dann gab's doch diese gesamte.
Verzögerung und Pannen beim Neubau der BND Zentrale, der BND zieht ja gerade äh von Pullach ähm nach Berlin,
und dann kommen noch so generelle Erwägungen und da sind wir eher bei der öffentlichen Darstellung ähm dieses ganze Cyber-Gedöns muss natürlich auch ähm beim BND äh stärker äh positioniert werden.
Schindler ist jetzt irgendwie dreiundsechzig oder sowas. Das heißt, er hätte das noch zweieinhalb Jahre gemacht, dann wäre der eh weggegangen und dann hat man sich gedacht, da wär's doch vielleicht äh besser, äh, wenn man jetzt da ein äh Reformer hinsetzt, der zehn Jahre jünger ist und das Ding,
durchziehen kann, ne? Ähm und vor allem na ja, wenn dein BND-Chef so oft in den Medien war, ähm dann,
Willst du das vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr? Also hat man jetzt, das ist eine interessante Personalienwahl, einen Herrn,
Kahl dahin gesetzt. Ähm jetzt habe ich mir den Bruno Karl genommen.
Ähm dreiundfünfzig Jahre alt, der war bisher Abteilungsleiter im Bundesfinanzministerium
und soll jetzt eben diesen BND Job übernehmen. Der hat seine Karriere neunzehnhundertfünfundneunzig als Referent im Bundeskanzleramt
angefangen und ist dann äh irgendwie in das Büro Schäuble gewechselt und seitdem ein sehr treuer Weggefährte von Wolfgang Schäuble.
Ähm über äh viele Jahre gewesen und,
man schildert ihn eben als einen äh eher Stillen, der zuhört und dann die Entscheidung trifft. Man kann sich also auch vorstellen, dass das jemand ist, der den größeren Teil der Politik schäuble
zumindest mitgetragen, mit ausgeführt und durchgezogen hat. Das scheint also jemand zu sein, der nicht.
Nicht ganz ohne ist und es ist natürlich auch interessant, äh dass so ein Wolfgang Schäuble jetzt eben ist, Schäuble ist ja auch schon etwas älter.
Äh offenbar in den in den wirklich wichtigen Punkten jetzt langsam so seine Leute äh unterbringen, ne? Also so
BND-Chef ist schon äh äh eine nennenswerte Position und er kann jetzt davon ausgehen, dass der Mann das noch zwölf Jahre machen wird. Ähm,
Das ist äh.
Also er war, muss man auch dazu sagen, ich meine Finanzministerium, das lenkt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen davon ab. Schäuble war ja nun auch lange Innenminister und der Brutokal war,
Leiter des Ministerbüros und Sprecher des äh des Ministers an der Stelle,
ähm später Leiter des Leitungsstabes, was auch immer das äh heißen mag. Ja, hat sich auch irgendeinen Doktor geholt. Da kann man sicherlich auch nochmal nachgucken,
Ja und dann ist er halt dem Schäuble quasi hinterher migriert, als der ins Finanzministerium gegangen ist
so noch dort Leiter des Leitungsstabes, also das klingt schon nach sehr nach äh vertrauter Position immerhin begleitet der ihn ja jetzt schon seit über zehn Jahren.
Ja muss man sehen, was äh der HK da jetzt für einen ähm,
Modus an den Tag legt, wie er gedenkt
da auch mit der Öffentlichkeit umzugehen, vor allem wie er gedenkt, äh auch hier mit dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss umzugehen, es sei denn, er wird äh just genau in dem Moment, wo der sein Abschütz äh Abschlussbericht
präsentiert, installiert. Vielleicht wollte man einfach auch nur sozusagen dieses Kapitel abschließen.
Ja, ein die Bundesregierung scheint das ja gerade eigentlich ganz gut zu spielen, der Schindler ist jetzt gerade mal nicht so massiv im Feuer.
Und dann machen wir das immer so, ja alt und so machen das Jüngeren mal hin, ne? Das äh ist schon.
Ist schon gut gespielt, ja? Irgendweil, was jetzt nochmal irgendwann auf den knallt.
Und knallen wird in irgendein Abschlussbericht ist NSA Untersuchungsausschusses. Da kann man dann irgendwann sagen ja ja genau der Ehemalige hatte das ist richtig, dass da,
einige Probleme waren, ne? Gut, dass wir den auch jetzt dann weg weggesicht haben. Jetzt haben wir ja hier jemand anders.
Jetzt wird alles gut.
Das ist schon gut, wenn da immer steht, äh der ehemalige Leiter, ne. Äh in so einem Bericht. Tja.
Aber wir bleiben ein bisschen bei den deutschen Geheimdiensten. Äh da gab es jetzt eine,
Recherche von Korrektiv, Korrektiv, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das hier mal so ausführlich erwähnt haben, das ist ein gemeinnütziges äh
Recherche kollektiv, da könnte man das nen,
investigative Journalisten, die sich eigene, die wirklich dann so längere,
Recherchen machen und die veröffentlichen gegründet, um eben mal ähm.
Wirklich Genoin neue Themen zu recherchieren und zu setzen. Und auch mal in Ruhe länger an an so einem Exposés äh zu arbeiten. Ähm,
eben ja so der der Medi, den dem medialen Korrektiv aus dem zum neuen ähm,
zum neuen Glanz äh zu verhelfen.
Ja, dass vor allem auch also ich kann jetzt die Arbeit im Einzelnen nicht immer genau bewerten,
und ähm habe auch hier auch nicht alles gelesen, auf keinen Fall. Nur was ich sehr interessant finde ist, dass Korrektiv im Prinzip,
sehr aktiv. Das äh lebt, was wir eigentlich immer wieder so in dieser Diskussion mit der Journalismus muss ich mal neu erfinden äh so verstanden haben,
Nun kam das aber nicht,
Wie ihr vielleicht auch nicht anders zu erwarten war, von irgendwie etablierten Strukturen, sondern die haben sich eigentlich mit einer komplett neuen, extremen, netzaffinen äh Struktur selbst erfunden
und ja schaffen jetzt äh genau das, was es eigentlich auch braucht, ein ein Brand für verlässliche Recherche.
Und haben auch ja schon mit diversen Berichten eine ganze Menge Aufmerksamkeit auf sich
Ich denke, was am weitesten zirkulierte von den Sachen, die sie gemacht haben
die Untersuchung zu dem MH siebzehn Abschuss, also dem Abschluss des ähm Malaysia Airlines Zivilflugzeugs über dem Kampfgebiet,
in der östlichen Ukraine, was ja mutmaßlich von russischen,
russisch-orientierten, aufständischen durchgeführt wurde, da gab's dann halt immer das ewige Hin und Her, die einen sagen das, die anderen sagen das.
Ist da halt mal mit einem Team losgezogen und hat
extrem aufwendige Recherche betrieben aufgrund von im Internet veröffentlichten Bildern et cetera und hat dann halt so eine ja gut nachvollziehbare in die Zehenkette auf den Tisch gelegt, die sie einfach zu dem
Schluss brachten, dass es sich hier sehr wohl um russisches Militärgerät äh handelte, was er aus Russland
in die Ostukraine verschafft wurde und dort dann eben zum Einsatz gebracht wurde. Also
dass äh ist einer. Es gibt auch noch viele andere Berichte, die man sich durchaus mal anschauen kann.
Über weiße Wölfe, also sind dann auch im Rechtsradikalen äh Milieu unterwegs. Es gibt was zu TTIP äh et cetera, Keime in Krankenhäusern
und so weiter und um das nochmal abzuschließen. Es gibt dann auch noch so eine Community, wo sie dann eben auch noch so ein Crowdfunding-Portal mit integriert haben, wo man dann eben selektiv einzelne Journalisten auch noch konkre,
bestimmten Recherchen beauftragen kann auf Basis von Crowdfunding, habe ich auch schon mal gemacht und ist äh ja alles sehr beeindruckend. Jetzt also.
Die haben leider, als sie sich damals, die haben sich ähm etwas etwas zeitgleich ihre Gründung da gemacht, wie diese Krautreporter.
Die Krautreporter hatten zu dieser Zeit,
irgendwie geschafft, den die größere mediale Aufmerksamkeit für ihr Projekt äh und auch äh Zug zu erlangen und auch ähm,
entsprechende Unterstützung zu äh erreichen in der Öffentlichkeit. Ähm,
das würde ich jetzt im im Nachhinein betrachtet als äh relativ bedauerlich sehen, denn dieses Projekt äh Krautreporter hat in meinen Augen
nie irgendetwas geliefert, was mich interessiert hätte, das Geld, was ich da reingeworfen habe und das traue ich heute noch. Ähm,
Da kann man also bei Korrektiv äh sehen, dass das irgendwie äh in meinen Augen, dass dass sehr viel bessere ähm oder sehr viel.
Ähm.
Stabilere Modelle haben.
Ja und vor allem, dass das ist das die haben das gefüllt, was man braucht. Krautreporter haben irgendeinen Report gemacht, so das war, also es war wirklich,
Dramatisch, was da geschehen ist für die für die Idee des unabhängigen Journalismus und die Korrektivleute, die haben's halt gemacht.
Genau, wobei man muss jetzt äh den Start auch äh insofern unterscheiden. Krautreporter hat sich halt ausschließlich auf Crowdfunding
äh gestartet. Korrektiv ist mit einer drei Millionen Euro äh Anschubfinanzierung von der äh Brost Stiftung gestartet
anderes Modell, aber von daher gab's da jetzt auch nicht so viel Bohei drum rum,
am Ende das ein bisschen wie bei Podcasts auch am Ende zählt halt was hinten rauskommt und was sozusagen ne geliefert wird und.
Müssen schauen, wie sich das jetzt weiterentwickelt, aber in den zwei Jahren haben die sich schon einen ganz guten Ruf erarbeitet, wie,
Stabil dieser Ruf äh erhalten bleiben wird, das wird man dann sehen,
Aber jetzt gibt's halt eine neue Recherche mit dem Titel die Staatsaffäre und da geht's halt um,
Netzpolitik Punkt org beziehungsweise die Ermittlungen gegen Markus und Andre von Netzbibliothek Punkt org. Was haben die denn herausgefunden.
Ne, sie haben im Prinzip einfach mal eine, sie haben nicht,
besonders viel Neues äh herausgefunden, aber sie haben einfach mal eine schöne äh Indizienkette nachgezeichnet.
Und es beginnt ähm mit,
mit der Gründung äh des Referats Spionageabwehrlandesverrat, Wirtschaftsschutz, Proliferation und ABC-Kriminalität im Bundesministerium des Inneren
Am sechzehnten sechsten zwanzig vierzehn. Da geht ihre Geschichte los. Und
ein knappes Jahr später, nämlich am fünfundzwanzigsten und am äh März und am sechzehnten April äh stellte ja dann Hans Georg Maaßen ähm Anzeige beim LKA in Berlin gegen eben,
unbekannt und Markus und André wegen.
Äh der Veröffentlichung der bis dato geheimen Haushaltspläne des Verfassungsschutzes. Ähm,
Da ging es ja dann darum, dass wo der Geheimdienst neues Personal einstellen will äh und was dieses Personal tun soll, nämlich soziale Medien überwachen und damit die Cybersicherheit erhöhen.
Das Ganze ging dann äh zu äh Harald Range. Dann gab's da noch das
äh Gutachten des Bundesamts für Verfassungsschutz, was den Range dann eben auch ermutigte, tatsächlich wegen Landes
Verrates zu ermitteln, dann wurde das irgendwann bekannt, dann gab war der Aufschrei am Ende gab's dann den äh,
Den Konflikt zwischen Heiko Maas und Harald Range und äh Range äh Namen in diesem Rahmen,
dann eben seinen Hut, beziehungsweise kriegte ihn aufgesetzt, der wurde ja dann zurückgetreten. Ähm.
Wer diese Affäre ganz gut überstanden hat, ist ja in der Tat äh der,
der Bundesinnenminister, der aufgrund,
dass sich die diese Affäre so konzentriert hat auf den Range äh so ein bisschen aus der Schusslinie war und sich nicht weiter äh die Aufmerksamkeit auf dieses Thema reichte nicht lange genug aus, als dass man.
Sich einfach mal die vernünftige und naheliegende Frage hätte stellen können, dass so etwas nicht passiert, ohne dass halt der Innenminister davon weiß, ja
dein Land verrat, dein Land verraten wird, dann weißt du das als Innenminister, ja? Das ist ja dann deine größte Sorge, dass.
Beziehungsweise wenn du es nicht weißt, dann ist das vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen äh dramatischer, ja.
Nun, ähm.
Wenige Wochen nach dem ganzen Landesvorratsding, nachdem das angetreten wurde. Äh hielt Maaßen eine Rede und sagte.
Das zerstört das Vertrauen in die Aufrichtigkeit der immer wieder eingeforderten parlamentarischen Kontrolle und beschädigt unsere Arbeit erheblich.
Da muss man sich echt mal äh genau überlegen. Er sagt, mein Vertrauen ich bin der Inlandsgeheimdienst.
Und ich habe jetzt das Vertrauen in die parlamentarische Kontrolle verloren. Als wenn es jemals eine Rolle gespielt hätte, ob der Geheimdienst der parlamentarischen Kontrolle vertrauen kann.
Der sagt also, die Abgeordneten, die seine Arbeit kontrollieren sollen, hält er für äh finde ich vertrauenswürdig. Wir haben es nicht verdient, dass sie mit seinem Vertrauen gesegnet werden, dass er dieses Parlament.
Dann sein Vertrauen in ihrer Aufrichtigkeit, also er zweifelt sozusagen an, dass sie auch aufrichtig handeln. Also, was habt ihr denn für Ziele? Was wollt ihr denn.
Was wollt ihr denn? Ihr wollt ihr wollt doch nur unsere Arbeit schädigen. Die parlamentarische Kontrolle ist meiner Arbeit schädlich. So und da haben die jetzt sehr schön mal zusammengetragen.
Ähm dass äh in den bisherigen Urteilen, da wurden mehrere genannt, ähm, Karlsruhe eben immer,
Also Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe immer für die Transparenz gegenüber dem Parlament entschieden hat. Ähm neunzehnhundertvierundachtzig gab's ein wegweisendes Urteil, dass sie sagt,
wo äh Karlsruhe sagte, also solange die Geheimhaltung sichergestellt ist, muss der, ne, muss es eine parlamentarische Kontrolle geben. Ähm.
Zweitausendneun äh,
gibt gab es ein Urteil, wo Karlsruhe eben sagte, ja, die Abgeordneten unterliegen ja ebenfalls dem Geheimschutz und daher ist das Parlament genauso berechtigt, wie die Regierung, diese Staatsgeheimnisse einzusehen. Ähm,
Man hatte damals versucht, sich auf das äh Staatswohl zu berufen. Ja und dann wurde gesagt, diese Begründung gilt nicht,
dafür dem Parlament diese Dokumente vorzuenthalten, weil sowohl,
war ja vom Parlament wirksame Vorkehrungen gegen das Bekanntwerden von Dienstgeheimnissen getroffen wurden,
Also Karlsruhe hat immer wieder geurteilt, dass das Parlament.
Sehr wohl ein Recht hat, das einzu.
Das Recht zur Einsitz, Einsicht von Staatsgeheimnissen hat, weil es,
Vorkehrungen trifft, dass diese Staatsgeheimnisse, Staatsgeheimnisse bleiben. Zwanzig vierzehn nochmal ein Urteil, in dem gesagt wird, es ist nicht zulässig vor dem Parlament und seinen Organen, Organisator.
Information.
Seinen Organen Informationen zum Schutz des Staatswohls geheim zu halten. Ja, also das heißt, der Staat wohl schützt du dich dadurch, dass du im Parlament etwas nicht sagst.
So und.
Entsprechend gesetzlich, also das waren die Urteile und entsprechend dem Gesetz zur parlamentarischen Kontrolle hat die Regierung allgemein einfach nur wenige Möglichkeiten, den Abgeordneten, geheimdienstliche Information und Dokumente zu verweigern.
Es gibt nur einen Grund der eine Geheimhaltung rechtfertigt. Wenn der Nachrichtenzugang.
Wenn dadurch der Nachrichtenzugang für die Geheimdienste gefährdet werde, also wenn dieses, wenn die Veröffentlichung, diese oder das Weit, das Teilen dieser Information mit dem Parlament, die Arbeit der Geheimdienste gefährdet.
Und der.
Maaßen scheint hier darauf oder es wird gesagt, dass der Maaßen wahrscheinlich darauf spekuliert hat, dass wenn er diesen Fall durchkämpft. Und wenn er ermittelt, dass dieses League ähm.
Die die undichte Stelle, die dafür gesorgt hat, die am Ende dafür verantwortlich war, dass dieses Dokument bei Netzpolitik Ork gelandet ist,
im Bereich des Parlamentes angesiedelt ist. Dann hätte er erstens äh,
richtig auf die Kacke hauen können und zweitens endlich einen Anhaltspunkt hat, diese Urteile ähm andersrum zu drehen und die parlamentarische Kontrolle zu schwächen,
Ja, dass das also in dem Moment alle sagen, solange hier nicht irgendwelche äh Belege sind,
die Arbeit des Geheimdienstes dadurch gefährdet wird, dass man diese Information mit dem Parlament teilt.
Müsst ihr dem Parlament gegenüber offen sein und er sagt, er vertraut dem Parlament nicht mehr, möchte.
Diesen diese Ermittlungen führen, hofft natürlich, geht davon aus, dass eben die undichte Stelle nicht im im Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz ist, wo wo ja trotzdem irgendwie hundertvierzig Leute auf dieses Dokument zugefahrten, sondern hofft.
Im Parlament die undichte Stelle zu finden und dann in einer längeren äh Ausführung eben darauf ähm hinzuarbeiten, dass ähm.
Eine, dass diese parlamentarische Kontrolle geschwächt wird, denn und das ist auch sehr schön herausgeführt. Im Moment gibt es ja den Konflikt, dass die Bundesregierung,
Dem Parlament, beziehungsweise dem Parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss äh zu den Geheimdiensten,
diese Selektorenliste ähm vorenthält, die ähm die NSA quasi dem BND diktiert hatte,
diese Bad Gelange, Bad Bad Aibling Geschichte, die wir gerade schon ansprachen, NSA hatte Zugang konnte in deutsche Abhörsysteme, Selektoren einpflegen und hat damit Halbeuropa ausspioniert. Diese Liste.
Weigert sich die Bundesregierung gerade dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss zu geben. Mit der
mit der Überlegung, dass die dann nicht mehr geheim bleiben wird. Und genau das hätte der Maaßen natürlich gerne gehabt für dieses Verfahren,
schon die die Präzedenzfall zu haben hier, wenn wir die Sachen ins Parlament geben, dann landen die bei Netzpolitik Ork und dann sind die in der Öffentlichkeit. Und das ist das, was hier jetzt ähm.
Ausgeführt wird und die Reporter von Korrektiv Ork hatten dann noch die Journalisten von Korrektivort, hatten dann noch irgendwie eine denkwürdige Begegnung mit August äh Hanning ähm
dem sie nachsagen, er wäre enttäuscht gewesen, dass der Fall Netzpolitik Org nach hinten losgegangen ist. Ähm und der wiederum sagt, die Schuldige.
Dass die Strategie gescheitert ist an dieser Netzkritik Org Veröffentlichung das Example zu statuieren, dass die Geheimdienste sich vom Parlament nicht mehr beziehungsweise weniger ausführlich kontrollieren lassen müssen, weil sie dem Parlament eben nicht trauen können, sei
Angela Merkel, weil sie nämlich die Ermittlungen der Beamten gestoppt habe, als sie gesehen hat, dass diese Nummer da losging.
Und dann sagt er, die Kanzlerin habe keine Achtung vor den Diensten.
Also ich in was für einer Welt diese Menschen leben, ja? Die Kanzlerin hat keine Acht, Achtung vor den Diensten. Big ist schuldig. Sie hat die Ermittlungen gestoppt und ähm dann.
Ist er sogar noch beleidigt, weil die Kanzlerin den BND noch nie besucht habe.
Was.
Korrektiv schreiben dann ganz schön das Bundeskanzleramt wollte den Vorwurf wieder bestätigen, noch dementieren.
Hanning mit seinen Zitaten erneut konferentiert, Meltenolakonisch. Ich bewundere ihr gutes Gedächtnis bei der Wiedergabe unseres Gespräches, bestätigt es also. Ja.
Ne? Bemerkenswert, ich wusste das nicht, also dass Angela Merkel nie den BND besucht hat?
Ja, siehst du mal. Die tun so viel fürs Vaterland.
Ist jetzt vor allem auch schon zehn Jahre äh.
Also vielleicht hat sie nur Hadin die besucht, also Hadding muss man ja nochmal dazu sagen, ist auch ein äh ehemaliger BMD äh Chef Pressi.
Bis zweitausendneun und jetzt hatten wir halt Herrn Schindler und jetzt kommt der Nächste. Also, die sind auf jeden Fall alle ordentlich beleidigt. Mal gucken, ob er äh ob sie einen Karl besucht.
Weiß nicht, ob jetzt unbedingt Schäuble die Schäubleachse und so ihre Stärke ist, aber das wird man dann sehen. Ja.
Also ich fand es man konnte sich ja schon.
Das ist jetzt nix.
Genuin Neues, es gab ja schon die den Gedanken, dass der äh Maaßen eben eigentlich an die Quelle dran will und das hat er ja auch gesagt. Aber dieses Mal in diese
in einen Angriff auf die parlamentarische Kontrolle umzumünzen und sich genau darüber Gedanken zu machen.
Finde ich hier ähm sehr genau und sehr ordentlich ausgeführt. Und jetzt kann man sich natürlich auch überlegen, dass,
vielleicht in der Tat Scheiße für die Geheimdienste, wenn sie ähm,
Im Rahmen der Kontrolle sich den äh den Parlamenten anvertrauen äh oder den Parlamentariern anvertrauen und diese dann tatsächlich die Arbeit der Geheimdienste ähm,
behindern oder stören?
In dem Falle muss man aber sagen, dass das bis mit dem bisherigen Veröffentlichung nicht der Fall war.
Ähm das waren Veröffentlichung, wo man.
Sehr klar argumentieren kann, dass die Öffentlichkeit da ein Recht und ein Interesse hat über diese Sachen informiert zu werden,
und es gleiche gilt auch für diese Selektorenlisten. Wenn der BND in Deutschland
gegen Europa spioniert, weil er irgendwelche, weil er sich von der NSA ungeprüft oder geprüft Selektoren geben lässt
Dann ist irgendwann der Spaß vorbei, wo man sagen könnte, okay, das das müssen wir jetzt der parlamentarischen Kontrolle entziehen, weil das den Geheimdiensten sonst schaden könnte. Und da ist, denke ich, die Linie, die, da verläuft die klare Linie, die
zu treffen ist, nämlich dass du zwar einerseits deine Geheimdienste, natürlich Geheimdienste sein lässt,
aber eben andererseits auch darauf achten muss, dass sie sich im Rahmen der rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen bewegen, die für sie gesteckt sind und wenn sie das nicht tun,
oder wenn sie massive Ausweitungen irgendwo vornehmen oder wenn sie sich in neue Bereiche vorwagen, dann ist das durchaus etwas, was äh das äh was die Öffentlichkeit äh zu interessieren hat. Und wenn das dann mal mit der Arbeit der Geheimdienste
interveriert? Dann ist das im Zweifel auch gut so, dass das passiert. Tja.
Mehr lässt sich da erstmal nichts zu sagen, oder?
Ja, also ich fand das sehr äh ich genau solche Dinge, ja, mal meiner Sache über über Jahrzehnte hinterherrecherchieren und das mal in auch im Rahmen einer größeren Strategie zu ziehen. Das finde ich
sehr gut, dass das da passiert ist, fand ich einen sehr guten Artikel.
So, dann äh müssen wir gleich noch beim Speeti vorbei und ein paar SIM-Karten kaufen.
Weil ähm jetzt langsam diese Angelegenheit umgesetzt werden soll,
Wir haben ja vor zwei Jahren äh auch drüber berichtet, dass äh die Bestandsdatenauskunft äh beschlossen wurde, wo man eben sagt, okay, wir wollen äh von den Telekommunikationsanbietern ähm.
Automatisiert die.
Die Bestandsdaten einsehen und durchsuchen können. Was sind Bestandsdaten? Bestandsdaten sind jene Daten, die sich nicht verändern, die eben die zu einem Anschluss gehören. Im, also das, was man Kundendaten nennen kann.
Ähm.
Und die Sicherheitsbehörden wollen eben automatisiert darin äh suchen können, vor allem auch mit unvollständigen Namensbestandteilen oder abweichenden Schreibweisen,
Um Terrorverdächtige zu suchen, weil sie teilweise nur wissen, wie die heißen, aber nicht, wie man den Namen schreibt.
Ist ja auch nicht mal so ganz einfach.
Ist teilweise nicht ganz einfach, es gibt relativ viele äh Möglichkeiten irgendwie äh Namen zu schreiben. Was ist so ein Name, der häufig falsch gewürdet.
Weil du hast halt generell das Problem, dass äh Namen aus dem arabischen, zum Beispiel der Halt a.
Arabische Namen.
Einfach 'ne ganz andere Transkriptionsregeln haben, das nicht einfach vollkommen klar ist, wie das geschrieben wird, das betrifft nicht nur Arabisch, sondern es betrifft eigentlich viele
nahmen, also insbesondere die mit anderen Schriftsystemen, so bei Gorillisches noch verhältnismäßig einfach und griechisch aber bei anderen ist es halt.
Aber in Deutschland haben die Terroristen ja eher Namen wie.
Knifflig.
Nico, Stefanie, Peter.
Peter. Hans, Hans. Ja.
Adolf, nee, keiner. Ähm so, die wollen jetzt äh die wollen also in diese Bestandsdaten einsehen und.
Das Blöde ist natürlich, wenn es dann eben anonyme SIM-Karten gibt und dem soll jetzt ein Riegel vorgeschoben werden.
Ähm ich vermute, dass sie da nicht so, das wird ihnen nicht unbedingt so gut gelingen, weil es eben jetzt auch schon seit vielen Jahren diese doch sehr äh laxe Praxis in im Verteilen äh,
von SIM-Karten gibt, aber ähm.
Wer also noch mit alten, einfachen Regeln mal eben an der Ecke eine SIM-Karte kaufen will, der solle das.
Ich äh finde da jetzt gerade keine Quelle äh dazu, wann tritt denn das in Kraft.
So sieht es der Hang, der.
So sieht es dem Maßnahmenkatalog Handlungsbedarf, Terrorismusbekämpfung vor, ähm auf denen sich die Koalitionsspitzen,
vor ein paar Tagen nachts verständigt haben. Also das wird dann jetzt in irgendeiner Form heruntergereicht werden. Wie gesagt, die gesetzliche Grundlage gibt's mit diesen Bestandsdaten.
Mit dieser Bestandsdatenauskunft eh schon seit zwanzig dreizehn, jetzt wollen Sie eben auch die einen geeigneten Maßnahmenkatalog umsetzen.
Um das zu ermöglichen, also sowas wie Personalausweis, Nummern geben.
Beim Kauf einer SIM-Karte, äh, Prüfung auf vielleicht unvollständige Registrierung oder nicht plausible Registrierung, Abgleich mit äh mit äh Einwohnermelderegistern und so. Da kriegt man natürlich schon über die Zeit ähm,
irgendwann äh Zucht und Ordnung rein und notfalls müssten die äh äh Telkos dann eben SMS an ihre Kunden schicken und sagen, hier wenn äh dich bis dann und dann nicht
namentlich registriert hast, schalten wir das Ding ab oder so, ne?
Da empfiehlt sich natürlich der Ringtausch. So eine anonyme Sinnkarte ist ja schnell mal verloren.
Ach so. Ja, also wird nicht mehr so lange dauern und der Spaß ist vorbei.
Was, ja, schade ist.
Aber dafür kriegen wir jetzt schnelles Internet.
Genau, wir AF äh super Internet kriegen wir jetzt bald. Das wird spannend, ey. Ja. Ähm.
Ähm wusstest du, dass du mich jetzt das Kupfer ist Glasfaser.
Nee. Ja.
Ja, also Krieg ist auch Frieden und Kupfer äh ist jetzt Glasfahrer. Hat die Telekom gesagt.
Ja, die Telekom hat schon viel gesagt. Ähm ich war sehr äh erfreut. Ich habe da jetzt gerade den Link nicht parat, aber Sigmar Gabriel hat irgendwie äh vor kurzem einen lichten Moment gehabt, einen seiner seltenen lichten Momente,
sagte,
Wir brauchen bis dann und dann einfach mal die weltweit beste Infrastruktur, was diese ganze Netzgeschichte angeht, wenn wir als in dieser Nation hier noch nennenswert ähm eine Rolle spielen wollen, ähm auf diesen Dingen, was sich äh Globus nennt.
Und er hat auch das Wort Glasfaser da in den Mund genommen und ich bin da sehr froh, dass er äh dass er da sich drum kümmern möchte. Und als Wirtschaftsminister ist er ja auch im Rahmen der Wirtschaftsförderung ähm durchaus ermächtigt und es wäre sehr schön, wenn er das tun würde.
Ähm währenddessen,
entscheidet sich die Telekom aber mit einer sag ich mal wirklich nicht wirklich brauchbaren Brückentechnologie,
sich dem Thema Ausbau der Infrastruktur zu nähern, nämlich dem Vectoring. Also die Zukunft,
kann nur sein, dass dieses komplette Land hier mit Glasfaser vernetzt ist,
wir überall eine großartige Infrastruktur in diesem Bereich haben. Diese äh dieser Schritt ist seit mindestens zwei Jahrzehnten.
Überfällig. Ähm es wurden damals auch erste äh Schritte unternommen mit den optischen Anschlussleitungen.
Äh die sie dann nie richtig ins Rennen gekriegt haben, dann haben sie äh mindestens oder vielleicht so mehr als zwei erzählt, aber wie dem auch sei. Ähm,
Oder weniger meine ich. Ja egal, also sie man hätte schon vor einiger Zeit anfangen müssen, Glas zu legen.
Und das ist nicht geschehen, nicht im nennenswerten Rahmen und jetzt stehen wir hier und der Bandbreitenbedarf,
steigt und die Telekom denkt sich, na ja, aber das mit dem Glas liegen, das ist ja auch teuer. Vielleicht können wir ja erstmal Vectoring machen und noch den letzten, das letzte Fitzelchen aus Kupfer rauskratzen,
an äh Datenübertragungsmöglichkeit.
Kupferkabel sind relativ alt und haben bestimmte äh physikalische Grenzen, die für äh Lichtwellenleiter in dem Ausmaß nicht gelten.
Und die Technologie, die sie da nutzen möchten, heißt Vectoring, Vectoring ähm ermöglicht, dann etwas höhere Übertragungsraten bis zu hundert Mbit im Download, vierzig Mbit im Upload,
In dem Interferenzen in der Modellierung,
so verringert und optimiert werden,
dass eben eine höhere DSL Übertragung auf dieser auf diesem Kupferadern möglich ist. Das geht aber nur, weil du ja quasi ähm.
Weil du ja quasi alle modulierten Signale auf der Kupferleitung kennen musst, um dann diesen Vectoring-Effekt zur Anwendung zu bringen, musst du den kompletten äh Netzabschlussknoten da kontrollieren.
Das heißt, es kann nur noch einen Anbieter geben.
Du kannst dir den nicht mehr teilen. Im Moment gibt's da ein äh
ein äh Abschlusspunkt und dann wird von dort äh da sitzen dann haben die haben die unterschiedlichen sich Ports drauf gemietet
pumpen dann das DSL zu ihren Kunden und das wird nicht mehr möglich sein, wenn der der Hauptverteiler kann nur noch von einem Anbieter
Betriebe durchgesetzt geführt werden. Das hieße, wenn die Telekom an diesen Verteilern Victoring macht,
dann können andere Betreiber dort keine eigene Technik mehr installieren und müssen die Ports.
Von der Telekom mieten, wodurch die Telekom einen massiven Wettbewerb Wettbewerbsvorteil hat. Ähm.
Noch hinzukommt, dass dieser Effekt, den man da erzielen kann auf der Kupferleitung mit der Leitungslänge abnimmt und.
Höchstens so über paar hundert Meter reicht. So nach sieben, achthundert Metern
ist dieser Effekt einfach nicht mehr nennenswert, dann bist du wieder oft auf alter DSL Performance, das heißt du kannst so ein paar hundert Meter um so einen Hauptverteiler knoten.
Ein bisschen erhöhte Übertragungsgeschwindigkeiten erlangen ähm zu dem Preis, dass du,
Die alte Infrastruktur äh weiter auf dem letzten Loch vers ähm und gleichzeitig deine Konkurrenten auf diesem Markt schlechter stellst. Was notwendig wäre, ist natürlich eben.
Äh Glasfaser zu legen und genau das entscheidet sich die Telekom jetzt nicht zu tun und es gibt,
Problem, dass sie nämlich damit von der dafür, von der EU-Kommission eine äh Freigabe brauchen.
Ob sie dieses exklusive Vectoring machen dürfen. Und da haben sie jetzt eine Stellungnahme von der Bundesnetzagentur bekommen, in der die Bundesnetzagentur äh,
Die Regulierungsbehörde für den Telekommunikationsmarkt in attestiert. Wir kommen nach nochmaliger intensiver Analyse zu dem Schluss, dass ein Victoring-Ausbau,
Der Narbe.
Das ist ein Victoring-Ausbau der Nahbereiche hilft, den Breitbandausbau zu fördern. Es werden weder der Wettbewerb außer Kraft gesetzt, noch werden andere Technologien ausgebremst. Ähm das ist eine,
ein Fazit dem ich mich äh nicht anschließen würde. Wie ich gerade schon generell ausgeführt habe.
Ja es ist wirklich hochproblematisch und es zeigt eigentlich diese ganze Debatte umwegtoring zeigt einfach nur wie sehr bisher einfach der Trend verschlafen wurde zumal ja.
Wenn wir jetzt hier mal darüber reden würden, dass mit dieser Technologie so etwas in der Größenordnung wie ein Gigabit pro,
Anschluss realisiert werden könnte. Da würde ich ja dann auch so ein bisschen durchatmen und sagen okay, ja äh,
Max Hands, weil ein Gigabit wäre heutzutage etwas
wo man sagen kann, da kann man jetzt auch mal so die nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahre drauf aufbauen. So, das ist das ist irgendwie, das hat genug Hub, da ist einfach äh so viel Luft nach oben für den einzelnen Nutzer und da ist auch,
sagen wir mal wirklich eine Vielzahl von Diensten wahrscheinlich realisierbar, die wir heute noch gar nicht so auf dem Zeiger haben,
Klar, mit mehr geht immer mehr so
Wir erinnern uns, als jetzt diese Drosseldiskussion zum Beispiel auf dem Mobilfunknetzen und DSL-Netzen kamen. Und dann diese Telekom, diese Haarsträubenden äh Statistiken aufgefahren hat mit, ja, was wollt ihr denn eigentlich? Ihr könnt euch doch drei Filme im Monat anschauen
ja äh wo man auch sagen muss so Leute,
welches Jahrhundert war jetzt nochmal gleich äh das wo ihr euch eingeloggt habt? Ähm.
Das ist halt genau dieser Punkt und ich glaube derzeit ist äh Deutschland so international im Breitband ein äh Breitbandranking irgendwo so im.
Irgendwo zwischen Platz zwanzig und Platz äh dreißig, je nachdem, wer und wie man zählt.
Und das ist natürlich haarsträubend für einen Land, dessen Wirtschaft einfach erheblich auch davon darauf aufbaut, dass eben eine,
entsprechende Infrastruktur da ist und so wie wir eine Infrastruktur in Straßen haben äh
eben einfach ein Handel ermöglicht, eine auch eine Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur lange Zeit hatten, die ja ihre äh ihres gleichen sucht, also Anfang der neunziger Jahre,
bis Mitte der neunziger Jahre war einfach Deutschland mal allen voraus mit dem ISTN Netzwerk.
Und ja, das hat man dann einfach eingebüßt. Man hat's vor allem auch deshalb eingebüßt, weil man eben immer wieder diesen Kupferkompromiss gegangen ist. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, okay, ja, hier mit DSL sind wir ja weit gekommen, gucken wir, was alles
möglich war ohne eben jetzt den gesamten Bestand auszutauschen nur diese,
Man sieht ja jetzt auch schon bei diesem Vectoring, dass das einfach nicht so das Silver Bullet ist, sondern dass man hier im Prinzip immer nur auch in extrem urbanen,
Gebieten irgendwelche Vorteile erzielen kann, siebenhundert bis achthundert Meter mag jetzt erstmal viel klingen, aber äh da gehst du halt fünfmal um die Ecke und so und dann musst du ja dann auch noch irgendwie hoch ins Haus. Also da fällt halt nicht viel bei ab und vor allem ist das halt auch etwas
was eben jetzt mal den wirklich benachteiligten Regionen überhaupt nichts hilft.
Äh es gab da noch einen sehr schönen Tweet von der deutschen Telekom, wo sie sagten, Vectoring-Ist-Glasfaser.
Ist grandios.
Ähm um das vielleicht kurz zu erklären, warum sie das sagen. Ähm tatsächlich liegen,
Bis zu diesem Hauptverteilerknoten.
Glasfaserkabel. An einigen Stellen. Das wollen sie bei diesem Victoring insbesondere machen. Sie haben da jetzt ein äh Modellprojekt in äh Bad Honnef, das deshalb im äh im,
Fokus der Aufmerksamkeit steht, weil sie dort das sogenannte Microtrenching äh zur Anwendung kommen lassen,
Also Mikrograben.
Statt also 'ne Schippe zu nehmen, die Straße aufzumachen, Loch zu graben unter Glasfaser reinzuwerfen, wollen Sie nun diese Faser schnell und billig
bis zu dem grauen Kasten legen, also der bis zum Hauptverteilerknoten, indem sie, ja, mit so einer großen Flex einfach einmal die Straße lang fahren, da einen fünfundzwanzig, eine fünfundzwanzig Zentimeter tiefe Rille äh ziehen
Und dann da die die Faser reindrücken.
Ja, an der Bordscheinkante, da wo das Ganze von dem eigentlichen Straßenverkehr noch etwas geschützt ist, dass man also so Difformierungen durch Fahrzeuge äh ein wenig geschützt ist, dass äh auch jetzt überhaupt nichts Neues. Das gibt schon äh
Seit vielen Jahren wird in anderen Ländern auch schon seit längerer Zeit gemacht
und ist aber halt jetzt kommen sie langsam auf dem Zeiger, dass man hier auch innovativ werden muss, um überhaupt erstmal Fasern zu verbuddeln. Aber das ist natürlich eine superschnelle Methode, kostet glaube ich auch nur ein Viertel und,
Also geht vor allem sehr schnell.
Dauert nur ein Viertel der Zeit und kostet wahrscheinlich äh sehr viel weniger als nur, ne? Ich meine, wenn da einmal mit, die haben ja so eine große Flex, wo man drauf sitzen kann, die hatten
Motor kann man mit fahren. Äh das geht äh geht relativ schnell, ist auch völlig in Ordnung. Und was machen sie dann? Jetzt gehen sie da in Bad Honnef zwei Millionen raus und irgendwie ein paar Mal die Straße lang zu fahren
Und sagen, werden dreißig Kilometer von dieser Faser verlegen. Vierundvierzig Multifunktionsgerätegeräte aufstellen.
Und dann neuntausend Haushalte in Bad Honnef mit,
Victoring-Fägen, DSL verbinden. Das heißt, sie fahren da mit ihr mit ihrer Trenchmaschine rum äh und legen den Leuten am Ende äh die letzten paar Meter legen sie dann da irgendwie dieses dämliche äh Kupferkabel statt,
Faser jetzt auch einfach mal ins Haus zu werfen,
und dann zu zu gucken äh wie's da rund geht. Ich meine, da könnte musst du, das ist ja dann nur ein paar Meter mehr, ne, du bist ja eh schon die Straße lang. Ähm das ist also.
Ja gut, ich meine ins Haus werfen, klingt einfach äh ist aber auch nochmal eine ganz andere Nummer. Man äh erinnert sich äh zum Beispiel in Friedrichshain.
Da war dieses Opal Pro.
Da da ist ja im Prinzip genau das mal probiert worden. Also man muss auch äh sagen, die Telekom hat's ja schon mal probiert so und ähm wollte tatsächlich dieses Glasfaser-Everyware einfach mal fahren. Ähm ja, Opal,
dass äh die sogenannten Opal-Gettos, die dadurch äh entstanden, weil einfach keinerlei Kupfer mehr ausgeräumt wurde
ne? Also da hat sie, haben sie es im Prinzip genau andersrum gemacht und sind dafür natürlich noch sehr viel mehr geprügelt worden. Schlicht und ergreifend deshalb, weil ihnen dann die eigentliche Anschlusstechnik äh zu teuer wurde
so, das war der eine Driving Faktor, der andere Driving Faktor war und das ist natürlich jetzt auch,
bei einer zukünftigen Glasfaserausbaugeschichte ein Problem, dass einfach die Hausbesitzer nicht mitspielen, ja, die einfach gesagt haben, so.
Äh was ihr wollt da jetzt unten einen neuen Hausanschluss legen, das heißt nur Geld. Und ähm das ist halt ähm,
Da wird halt auch klar, dass es jetzt kein Problem, was jetzt nur von einem Unternehmen gelöst werden kann, sondern was wir hier eigentlich benötigen, wäre einfach ein ähm,
Ja eine staatliche Aktivität so in der Größenordnung des Kabelfernsehausbaus, den wir äh ja in den achtziger Jahren hatten, der auch wunderbar funktioniert hat,
Aber der Vorteil war, dass der Telekommunikationsminister damals noch an den Kabelfirmen irgendwie beteiligt war. Vielleicht äh müssten wir da sozusagen einfach mal in das Ministerium Alters besitzen. Statt Herrn Dobrindt irgendein Glasfaserhersteller
mal ins äh Ministerium reinholen. Das ist dann zwar ausreichend korrupt, aber das liegt dann vielleicht auch mal was.
Sprich man muss einfach den Rahmen schaffen, man muss den Rahmen schaffen für Hausbesitzer, man muss den Rahmen schaffen für
wegerecht, man muss den äh Rahmen schaffen für die eigentlichen Investitionen und in dem Moment, wo man eben auch den Mumm hätte, zu sagen, okay und diese Infrastruktur, die wir jetzt aufbauen, die ist aber dann nicht privat,
und das ist dann eben eine öffentlich-rechtliche Struktur, die äh von uns einfach äh untervermietet wird,
ähnlich könnte man's in Zukunft auch mit Mobilfunk machen im Übrigen und dann,
ja, dann wird ein Schuh draus und dann ist das einfach ein Maßnahmenprojekt über zehn Jahre oder zwanzig Jahre, aber am Ende äh lächeln wir dann halt äh,
nur noch leise, wenn's heißt, oh, ich habe nur einen Gigabit zu Hause.
Also ich möchte mir nochmal diese diese Opalgeschichte das ist ja wirklich ein ein sowas von geil, ja? Die haben also sie legen,
diese, sie haben dieses Glasgelegt, überall dieses war im in hauptsächlich in
den neuen Bundesländern, weil dort teilweise einfach auch gar keine Telefoninfrastruktur gab und da haben sie gesagt, okay, hier gibt's noch nicht mal Kupfer, dann werfen wir jetzt Gas rein, da machen wir, wenn wir hier schon mal jetzt nochmal Infrastruktur bauen, dann machen wir das mal direkt zukunftsfähig.
So
Ich zitiere die Wikipedia. Als später breitbandige Internetzugänge auf DSL-Basis eingeführt wurden, erwies sich die Glasfasertechnologie im Ortsnetz
die vorher modern und zukunftsweisend gewirkt hatte als schwerer Nachteil
Die bevorzugte DSL-Technologie erfordert eine durchgänge Kupferleitung
und arbeitet nicht auf passiven Glasfasern. Es gab zwar schon Technologien für Datenübertragungen über Glasfaser, jedoch war die Technik dafür so teuer, dass es rentabler war, nochmals die Straßen aufzureißen. Neben dem Glasfaserkabel ein Kupferkabel zu legen und die Technik für Kupfer
anzuschaffen.
Das Problem ist heute nicht die Glasfaserleitung als Teilnehmeranschlussleitung, sondern die Opaltechnik mit der Kombination von Glasfaser und Kupferleitung.
Die Kombination aus Glasfaser und Kupferleitung wird gerade in Bad Honnef gebaut,
Das lesen sie, legen sie wieder eine Phase, diesmal nicht bis ans Haus. Ähm aber da da hauen sie dann am Ende dieses Victoring dran und machen die letzten Meter mit diesem Kupfer und das wird, das ist auch wieder so eine Sache, wo man am Ende sehen wird, dass es günstiger ist, die Straße einfach nochmal aufzureißen.
Na gut, ich meine, es macht ja durchaus Sinn an diese Verteilerknoten schon mal mit Glasfaser ranzukommen. Also der der Teil, den finde ich äh vollkommen in Ordnung und ich glaube, diese diese Probleme, die du machst, also bin ich jetzt nicht ganz so sicher, das hatte auch irgendwie was mit dem verwendeten Glasfasertyp zu tun.
Sie konnten die am Ende gar nicht mehr benutz.
War das nicht irgendwie so Single-Mode, Multimode, irgendwie so ein.
Irgendwas war da krum.
Wir reden jetzt äh über Sachen, die wir nicht vollständig durchschauen
Insofern habe ich da jetzt keine Bedenken und selbstverständlich stimmt es auch, dass in dem Moment, wo jetzt ein Victoring Rollout sozusagen forciert wird, das eben zwangsläufig bedeutet, dass mehr dieser Anschluss äh Kästen eben,
mit Glasfaser angebunden werden, was letzten Endes natürlich auch eine Vorstufe für einen Fibertosah Home bedeuten kann,
Trotz alledem haben wir natürlich jetzt dieses Wettbewerbsproblem und äh das ist natürlich nicht ohne.
Wir werden also die die Nachwelt wird sehen, dass wir damals schon wussten, wie wir sehenden Auges in den ins Verder.
Eine weitere Verzögerung des Breitbandausbaus.
Hey irgendwann brauchst du das auch nicht mehr. Irgendwann ist vorbei. Irgendwann kannst du aufhören.
Ja, dann kannst du noch aufhören. Wie was finden Singularität oder was?
Nein, weil einfach dann brauchst du dann das Land in ist ja hier keiner mehr, hauen alle ab.
Meister werden einfach nur noch Trommeln verteilt und.
Ja, da kannst du jetzt, wenn du jetzt in Brandenburg irgendwie Infrastruktur aufbaust oder so, ist dann auch zu spät. Die Leute sind jetzt weg. So, ähm.
Noch was Schönes? Sehr schön eigentlich. Dafür da hat jemand äh mal äh nachgedacht. Alexander Hanf ähm mit zwei F. Ähm.
Irgendwie CEO einer so einer Datenschutz äh Geschichte ähm der hat mal bei der EU-Kommission nachgefragt,
wie denn AdBloger Detektoren.
Im Bereich im Lichte der E-Privacy Richtlinie zu sehen sind,
Die E-Privacy Richtlinie, auch die sogenannte Cookie-Richtlinie,
besagt nämlich dass für jede Speicherung und Erlangung von Informationen vom Endgerät eines Nutzers.
Ähm diese Richtlinie gilt und man da eine.
Eine Einwilligung des Nutzers braucht, das heißt äh die Weißfingerprinting und so ist erstmal gar nicht erlaubt.
Was äh jetzt kann man diese Richtlinie äh so oder so sehen. Ähm dein Device meldet sich ja schon bei dem Webserver und sagt, ich bin ein, was weiß ich, ein Internet-Explorer auf dem Windows XP.
Oder so und äh insofern gibt's da ein langes Hin und Her, aber wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ist diese,
Richtlinie auch dafür verantwortlich, dass man jetzt überall diese Cookie-Warner kriegt. Wo steht Vorsicht? Wir machen hier Cookies. Wir wir speichern etwas über dich,
äh wenn du uns besuchst. Und jetzt hat dieser Alexander Hanf gesagt, na ja, wenn offenbar gehe ich doch auf diese Seite.
Und diese Seite findet etwas über mich heraus, über die Konfiguration meines Gerätes, nämlich ob ich nun diese dämlichen Werbedinger anzeige oder nicht,
Und äh das geht doch gar nicht, weil das dürfen die ja nicht. Und äh er hat dann eine ähm eine Antwort bekommen.
Dass eben äh.
Jegliches Auslesen von Informationen über Wett, weil von den Webseitenbesucher unter Artikel fünf Absatz drei der Richtlinie fällt, also auch das Abrufen der Information, ob der einen AdBlocker nutzt oder nicht und deswegen gemäß Artikel fünf, Absatz drei
wäre
eben für diesen Vorgang eine Einwilligung des Nutzers notwendig, da die Speicherung von Informationen oder der Zugriff auf Informationen, die bereits im Endgerät eines Teilnehmers oder Nutzers gespeichert sind
nur gestattet ist, wenn der Teilnehmer oder Nutzer auf der Grundlage von klaren und umfassenden Informationen seine Einwilligung gegeben hat.
Das passiert bei der Edlockerüberprüfung nicht. Ähm das ist jetzt nicht,
rechtlich bindend, was die EU-Kommission da gesagt hat, aber natürlich äh politisch äh durchaus einflussreich und wir werden sehen, in äh wie fern
das in Zukunft eine Rolle spielen wird. Ähm! Es gibt ja auch noch immer diese anhängigen Verfahren wo der Axel-Springer Verlag.
Äh gegen den Hersteller eines Edblockers und gegen einen Youtuber ähm vorgeht, die.
Es Menschen ermöglicht harten eine Ed-Blockersperre zu umgehen. Ähm, interessanter, interessanter Fall, aber es wäre sehr schön, wenn wenn man quasi Seite besucht und die Seite muss erst.
Ja, wenn sie uns besuchen.
Willigen sie ein, dass wir Speicher, dass wir erkennen, ob sie einen Edlocker benutzen oder nicht? Nein, will ich nicht ein und dann kannst du halt die Seite im Zweifelsfall trotzdem nicht sehen. Also das ist Datenschutztrolling, aber wir werden mal sehen, äh wohin das führt.
Ist vor allem auch also die Auslegung finde ich auch so ein bisschen
gedehnt so, ne? Also ob das jetzt wirklich unter Device Fingerprinting äh fällt. Klar, äh da wird Code in meinem Browser aktiv, der quasi den Zustand dieser Webseite in irgendeiner Form interpretiert, aber
da gibt's sicherlich tonnenweise anderen Code, der das letztlich genauso tut, nur mit anderen äh Zielen und von daher
bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das hier wirklich Bestand haben kann. Aber es äh wie du schon sagst, hm, lustiger, troll.
So, dann kommen wir jetzt zu den äh Kurzmeldungen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir diese FBI iPhone Geschichte noch zu Ende gebracht hatten.
Weiß ich auch nicht mehr so ganz genau, aber ich glaube, wir hatten das nicht ähm nicht gebracht, das nicht als separate Meldung vielleicht äh ist, sondern mal runtergefallen. Aber wir erwähnen's halt einfach.
Am Ende haben sie es mit der Hilfe irgendeiner Schädigfigur äh aufgemacht.
Genau, also beim wir reden jetzt über den Apple Versus äh FBI-Fall, wo ja das FBI von Apple wollte, dass sie äh Maßnahmen ergreifen in Form von dem Bereitstellen von Software und anderen Dienstleistungen, um eben diese Zugangssperre
den Passcode des äh Telefons zum Gehen des iPhone fünf C's was sich halt im ähm,
Besitz stimmt nicht so ganz, aber sozusagen was so ein Businesstelefon war, was eben diesem Attentäter, äh, Kalifornien,
zugeordnet wurden konnte und na ja, Apple wollte halt nicht, lange Geschichte. Am Ende hat ja das FBI zurückgezogen,
und gesagt, wir brauchen eure Hilfe nicht. Übrigens auch in einem zweiten Fall in New York, mittlerweile,
Genau dasselbe Spiel auch nochmal, also auch dort haben sie gesagt, sie hätten jetzt Informationen bekommen oder Maßnahmen ergriffen, die ihnen eben den Zugang zu diesem zweiten Telefon auch ermöglicht,
Und ja, was dann aber halt im Nachgang eben noch äh festgestellt wurde ist, einerseits hat sie der ganze Spaß halt irgendwie über eine Million Dollar gekostet.
Was da ist die Quelle übrigens interessant. Die haben,
dieser FBI-Typ, der, der da als Quelle berufen wird, hat äh gesagt, wir haben dafür viel bezahlt, mehr als ich noch in diesem Job verdienen werde, bis zu meiner äh.
Das hat man dann mal ausgerechn.
Aber das halte ich für äh also das ist eine relativ ich halte diesen Preis irgendwie für schwierig. Äh für auch diese Behauptung. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie so viel dafür bezahlt haben. Ich glaube, dass sie eher absichtlich diese
Zahl so hoch zirkulieren lassen, damit die Leute sich ärgern und und sagen, scheiß Apple hat uns jetzt irgendwie eine Million an Steuergeldern gekostet
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie das dafür bezahlt haben. Und wenn, dann haben sie, wenn, dann haben sie das Geld dafür bezahlt, dass sie's jetzt immer können.
Immer mit diesem einen Telefon, genau, mit diesem einen Telefontyp. Ja, das äh kann natürlich sein.
Wenn Sie das nicht brauchen. Das Interessante ist.
Nichts gefunden.
Wir haben nichts gefunden, natürlich nicht. Das war das Arbeitstelefon von dem Typen und der hat eh beim Staat gearbeitet. Du bist Terrorist und irgendwie beim Department of Health. Ja, du, wenn du Terrorist bist und du hast ein Telefon von deinem Arbeitgeber und das ist das Department of Health.
Ja, vor allem das andere, sein anderes Telefon war irgendwie weitgehend zerstört und geschreddert worden von ihm, das lag irgendwo im Papierkorb, also das ähm ja, aber.
So, fertig. Dann haben wir äh Microsoft äh die sich äh vor Gericht.
Äh das Recht erstreiten wollen äh ihre Kunden über äh Anfragen von Behörden zu unterrichten. Ähm,
Haben Sie also gegen das hier klang jetzt gegen das Justizministerium, denn in den vergangenen achtzehnten Monaten hat die US-Regierung von Microsoft, also in anderthalb Jahren in zweitausendfünfhundertsechsundsiebzig Fällen,
verlangt die Anfragen zu Nutzerdaten geheim zu halten. Also haben quasi von Microsoft,
Angefragt Daten haben die bekommen und Microsoft durfte sollte darüber stillschweigend bewahren. In zweitausendfünfhundertsechsundsiebzig Fällen. Ähm.
Und da sagen sie halt diese Geheimhaltung ist faktisch, wird uns faktisch immer auferlegt und das heißt nicht,
dass hier dieses Geheimhalten die Ausnahme ist, sondern die Regel und diese Regel,
möchten wir so nicht haben, denn das ist schädlich, sowohl für die Kunden als auch für für uns und deswegen klagen wir gegen diese Geheimhaltungspflichten.
Ja, ist interessant, ne? Wie sich jetzt da so ein bisschen das ähm Blatt wendet und die ganzen Silicon Valley Firmen einfach offen revultieren und sich äh mit allen Möglichkeiten versuchen, zu wehren.
Es gab ja auch ein paar kleinere äh Tricks. Man erinnert sich, als das mit Snoten am Anfang äh losging und überhaupt erstmal so die Frage im Raum stand. Äh wie oft hat
wurde denn so ein Unternehmen überhaupt schon, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was die Maßnahme war, aber so so in der in der Dimension der ähm.
Horausgabe aller Daten, wie wie oft gab's eben solche Anfragen und dann.
Glaube ich, Apple damit an, irgendwie auf einer Webseite zu schreiben. Bisher hatten wir das noch nicht.
Weil du darfst halt, wenn's nicht passiert ist, darfst du halt sagen, dass das nicht passiert ist. In dem Moment, wo man diese Information verschwunden wäre, wäre klar, dass es passiert ist. Gut, aber in diesen regelmäßigen kleinen äh Datenanfragenfällen, die einfach eben tausende Male passieren pro Jahr.
Ähm geht eigentlich eben nur die direkte Benachrichtigung, wo halt ein Unternehmen das denn eben auch einfach mitteilen kann und das dürfen sie eben nicht und dagegen gehen sie jetzt vor.
Dann gab es eine äh schöne ähm,
Demo, äh Obama hat vermutlich seinen letzten Deutschlandbesuch gemacht,
Präsident äh bei der Hannover Messe und das wurde als äh Auslöser genommen nochmal in Sachen TTIP
loszulegen. Ähm! Da gab's eine sehr große Demo, ähm! Die Veranstalter haben irgendwie von bis zu neunzigtausend Menschen gesprochen, die Polizei von fünfunddreißigtausend Menschen
also irgendwo dazwischen üblicherweise liegt dann die tatsächliche Teilnehmerzahl.
Es gab dann auch sehr äh skurrile äh Plakate der Initiative neuer sozialer Marktwirtschaft für TTIP,
die also wirklich also das was wird echt schwierig mit dem Trolling so, wenn die so weitermachen. TTIP ist ho, ja.
Mit Merkel und Obama im üblichen Ding.
Das ist wirklich echt total mega absurd und diese Initiative, neue soziale Marke.
Sowieso absurd. Das ist das ist mit, das das der übelste wirklich seit seit zehn Jahren hier genießen dürfen.
Aber ich glaube, das Plakat konnte auch keiner so richtig ernst nehmen.
Ich frage mich, also in letzter Zeit scheinen sehr häufig irgendwo in irgendwelchen Agenturen Leute zu sitzen und sich zu sagen, so ehrt.
Erfolg vor acht Jahren war das Plakat ja noch toll und lustig und dann durfte man ja gerne dran glauben, dass irgendwie Obama Hope ist, aber äh ich weiß nicht, den Brand hat er irgendwie nicht so richtig durchgezogen.
Von daher bisschen albern, aber bemerkenswerte Teilnehmerzahl.
So, dann gibt es ein äh Kartellverfahren der Europäischen Kommission gegen Google, äh die werfen Google vor mit unzulässigen Vertragsbedingungen äh über seinen Mobil,
äh Betriebssystem Android seine marktbeherrschende Stellung auszubauen.
Ähm da solche Sachen dauern in der Regel lange und sind äh eigentlich egal, weil der Markt im im weiteren Verlauf äh sein Übriges tut
aber es sei der Vollständigkeit halber erwähnt, äh wenn nämlich dann irgendwann Google zerschlagen wird, dann haben wir's können wir sagen Logbuchnetzpolitik berichtet.
Ja, wobei das ein bisschen merkwürdig ist, das äh so ein bisschen wie diese Geschichte damals mit Microsoft und dem Internetexplorer, die fand ich auch schon so ein bisschen absurd. Ähm.
Es geht dabei um diese Vorinstallationen,
der Google Apps, ne? Also Google sagt ja, dass es Android ist ein freies Open Source Betriebssystem, jeder kann das nutzen und verändern und das ist ein Motor für Innovationen,
Was glaube ich sehr. Äh äh
was glaub ich stimmt, sie treffen dann mit ihren Partnern freiwillige Vereinbarungen, jeder kann Android ohne Google benutzen
Amazon macht das ja auch, führen sie an, ne? Also auf diesen Kindles und so äh ist ja Android drauf. Da ist der Google weggeschnitten
der Amazon reingemalt.
Gibt's auch in äh in China gibt's einfach extrem viele Telefonhersteller, die halt mit Android ausliefern, wo halt kein Google drauf ist.
Genau und der eigentliche Vorwurf ist sozusagen. Willst du eine musst du alle nehmen was halt ja.
Schwierig zu argumentieren ist so ein bisschen jetzt in dem in dem äh Umfang. Also wozu kann man denn ein Unternehmen jetzt verpflichten? Also sie sie bieten halt eine Dienstleistung an, nämlich hier sind irgendwie unsere Google-Apps, wenn ihr die haben wollt, dann zack, ja.
Na sie sind daran gebunden, also was der der Kern des Vorwurfs ist nicht, dass sie oder erscheint nicht zu sein, dass Google diese Apps als vorinstalliert.
Mit ausliefert, sondern dass Google so eine ähm,
daran bindet, dass du auch auf den Google App Store zugreifen kannst. Also das ist quasi das Google-Paket und dann ist auch Google App Store und der Google App Store ist oder Playstore oder wie der heißt. Und der ist eben der äh der größte.
Das größte App-Ökosystem in dem Bereich. Das heißt, du kannst wohl offenbar nicht Google App Store, aber nicht den ganzen anderen Google-Kram, aber Android, so das scheint da irgendwie die Fahne zu sehen, aber wie gesagt.
Ich sehe, dass ähm jetzt gerade nicht als ein, als ein Thema, was mich nennenswert interessiert.
Mich auch nicht.
Gut.
Dann schon lieber das Ende der Sendung.
Ja das interessiert mich jetzt auch langsam.
Genau. Gibt jetzt auch nicht mehr viel zu sagen, außer, dass jetzt mal wieder eine wilde Woche ansteht.
Ähm es ist Republika in Berlin, da herrscht ja dann immer eine gewisse Aufregung, zumindest äh schleichen sich wieder viele Netzaffine Menschen äh durch die Stadt und äh,
Da gibt's dann halt allerlei Brumborium. Wer von euch auf der Republika ist, kleiner Hinweis,
Das Sendezentrum hier unser Podcast äh Community, Projekt.
Wird auf der Republica auch mit einem Ministandort vertreten sein
dieses großen Gewühls in der zentralen Halle. Äh ich habe jetzt grad hier die Standnummer hier im Kopf, aber ihr findet das schon. Gibt's ähm
so einen Ort, wo man halt andocken kann als Podcaster, als äh Podcasthörer, et cetera, andere Podcaster treffen kann, das ist halt einfach mehr so als kleiner Community, habe gedacht, damit's einfach mal einen Ort,
wo man sich da äh finden kann
wir werden auch noch die Möglichkeit bieten dort Podcasts aufzunehmen, so ähnlich wie auf dem Kongress wir das gemacht haben mit diesem Podcast Tisch, das heißt wenn ihr von,
Vor Ort einfach Lust habt irgendwie eine Sendung aufzunehmen, dann tretet in Kontakt mit uns und dann könnt ihr das,
machen ähm es gibt da keine Bühne, es gibt da kein, kein, kein Video äh Klimbem nichts Großes, wie wir das in den Jahren davor mal gemacht haben, das war einfach nicht zu stemmen,
allein schon deshalb, weil direkt im Anschluss ja dann unsere Subscribe Konferenz äh stattfindet ähm wo man sich jetzt vielleicht gerade noch soeben nochmal äh anmelden kann, wenn man's noch nicht getan hat, aber da machen wir jetzt auch bald den Sack zu.
Ja und das ist ja unsere halbjährliche Veranstaltung die jetzt sich umbenannt hat eben in Subscribe. Früher war das ja der Pott Love Workshop und jetzt wollen wir das Ganze langsam in ein Konferenzformat überführen
und gehen dann übrigens auch im Oktober nach München damit. Dazu vielleicht später auch nochmal mehr. An dieser Stelle sollte das jetzt erstmal reichen als Werbeblog.
Erklär mal, was heißt jetzt da in dem in dem Großen? Äh also in dem.
Wenn du, wenn du in die Station reinkommst, dann hast du auch diesen großen Freibereich sozusagen in der Bitte. Links und rechts hast du so die Vortrags äh Hallen.
Also in dem Hauptbereich wirklich in dem großen.
In dem großen Gewusel da in der Mitte, genau da drin.
War allem, dass es positiv oder negativ.
Ich hätte einen anderen Standort schöner gefunden, zumal sich ja dieses Jahr bei der Republika etwas ändern wird, der Hof, der ja immer so ein bisschen der zentrale Quatschort war
auch am Abend wird dann äh am Abend nicht mehr zum Einsatz kommen, sondern das Ganze verlagert sich auf die andere Seite,
und da diese allerletzte Halle, die hatten wir eigentlich so ein bisschen im Auge, aber das hat leider nicht geklappt. Egal, jetzt gibt's auf jeden Fall einen Anlaufpunkt. Mal gucken, wie das dieses Jahr auf der Republika
funktioniert's. Ähm es gibt ein paar Änderungen äh,
die ich tendenziell begrüße, ob die im ausreichenden Maße stattfinden, weiß ich nicht, also sie haben so Sachen wie diese Kopfhörervortragsseele sterben lassen, weil das war einfach furchtbar,
und ähm es sind auch weniger Vorträge gleichzeitig,
Also es hat sich ja so enorm aufgebläht gehabt, dass man einfach irgendwann überhaupt nicht mehr wusste, wo oben und unten ist und ja, das ist tendenziell zu begrüßen, ob das in einem ausreichenden Maße ähm stattgefunden haben wird, wird man dann danach,
sehen, da werden wir uns natürlich auch nochmal zusammenfinden, um da ein kleines Review abzugeben.
Hast du noch was zu sagen.
Äh ich glaube heute nicht.
Na ja gut. Da sagen wir tschüss, bis bald.
Was sagen wir denn beim Militärzugschuss.
Weiß ich nicht.
Er wird nicht tschüss gesagt, ne? Er wird stehend gestorben.
Amen. Hol der Bayer.
Jawohl Herr Major.